Tony starts off this hour in North
Carolina hi Tony welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show thank you so much and
appreciate you guys being there I just
got back from vacation and listen to
your money make over twice and many of
the podcast I'll quit watching the news
and just listen your podcast now oh
thank you well it's a whole lot better
than the news two issues well everything
is in plan testtree
and I'm plain old signed up for the
finest peace university actually this
afternoon I know I just started because
I just you know really got into this
started baby step two my wife is a
little nervous but I think she's on
board two credit cards will soon be gone
I paid one off every month but I've
heard you say something on one of your
podcast that it doesn't matter get rid
of it because it's too easy to use and
you're so right about that I'm working
at home right now because of the Kovan
but I'm starting to see the freedom
better Walt I'm 68 years old I enjoy
want to do but I think I would really
like to either either retire or at least
just go part-time someplace again I love
it but and and I know that money is
there but I'm still nervous and you say
pays things off and once I started
putting stuff on a spreadsheet it
started making some sense of how much
interest I was paying total debt
including the house is $80,000 I know
you'll be there $7,000 a checking
account and I have five thousand dollars
in the starter emergency fund I did that
as soon as I got back from vacation now
some people wouldn't understand I got a
hundred sixty thousand dollars in
coupons and there's going to be another
hundred coming as soon as we get rid of
some property that is a family member
from in the state and it sounds like a
no-brainer but my potent
income right now is around 80 so that
includes you know the job and Social
Security so what's your plan what I'm
trying to do is just decide is a smart
thing just to go pay everything else and
then you know sit there and then you
know get control of expenses
and since I won't have the house I would
love to pay you know move to where my
grandchildren are well why wouldn't you
just have to get well I'll tell you the
reason I haven't so far is because
financial people that I've dealt with
you telling me this about what they
think I said why wouldn't you pay off
your debt you got a hundred thousand on
the way when it comes you can just pay
off everything or and never even touch
your mutual funds right correct why
wouldn't you
I guess because I've been nervous about
things like that because I've always
worried about the future that wasn't
what I was worried about future and make
me be debt-free yeah you said the money
was there Tony you said the money's
there
what are you truly afraid of I guess
it's not being there in case of an
emergency
yeah but one thing I'm one thing I will
say this you know some listening your
podcasts and stuff it's made me at least
I think I'm on the way to doing that but
I just that's why I wanted to run to run
that buy it I know it doesn't make sense
at all well if you listen if you pay off
everything off and you're miserable you
can go right back in debt it's a great
point you can always try that again
somebody will give it to you oh god
you're gonna be alright sir you are
finding your way through this okay so I
want to ask you this cuz you've done
this for so long so here he is he's got
the money and he's still scared if I
take this big chunk of money and I pay
off my house or excuse me pay off the 80
grand in debt which is house and
everything that's everything he's going
what if an emergency happens and I think
he fails and I've got a chunk of my you
still got a chunk of money but you have
no bills well in emergencies it doesn't
cost much to live when you don't have
any debt right so your your you know
your burn rate your survival rate is
very very low yeah
and so you can survive a long time when
you don't have your payment's yeah it's
it's like you don't need it your
emergencies a lot less of an emergency
when you're dead free I know what kind
of emergency well that's family yeah I
should end on that an income emergency
that right true you know if you lost
your income or something like that
what's what happens in people's minds
and it's mine and yours too and it is we
were drawing security from one thing and
then we start thinking about how to get
to the future and we can't see or feel
the security he doesn't feel the
security of being debt-free like I do
cuz I have been for 30 years and so he
instead he's getting security from the
hundred sixty eight thousand a mutual
funds one hundred thousand us on the way
and so that is three hundred sixty eight
thousand minus eighty still leaves you a
quarter-million dollars that's right and
so you're gonna be okay you're gonna be
fine just the question is you know it's
just you're transferring the sense of
security to debt freedom away from a
poly cash and that's an intellectual
exercise and a spiritual and emotional
exercise and all of those things and
that's the best thing that's the journey
he's on he's wandering down the path
he's heading in the right it's so good
you just outlined it's really the
unknown there he just doesn't know it
yeah so once he feels it I know I got
tell me once you're dead free you won't
ever if you if you had to pay a price to
get there if you had the crap scared out
of you now if you just got out of debt
you don't think a thing about you go
back in but its debts everywhere right
but if you went through like what we
went through losing everything and once
we got out there there's no way I'm
going back the security that that gives
me is greater than a pile of money and
he's gonna pile it up pretty quick
running through his numbers oh yeah
he's gonna have 20 left over right after
that hundred he could go part-time he
wants to retire here you go part-time
take that part-time cash and just keep
staying there's grandbabies I heard that
REM say that yeah that's important thing
right there I don't know how great
grandbabies are gonna be I'd been nicer
to their parents